is the early birds for Oppenheimer a
sign of a serious breakthrough or is it
a dud in their early reviews critics are
basking in the glow of what might just
be a masterpiece J Robert Oppenheimer
changed the world as we know it when he
led the Manhattan Project to develop the
atomic bomb and his story is on its way
to the Silver Screen since his
announcements the biopic Oppenheimer has
been the talk of the Cinematic world and
for good reason with Christopher Nolan
in a director's chair Ludwig gorenson
responsible for the musical score and
the Stellar cast led by peaky blinders
favorite and frequent Nolan collaborator
Killian Murphy the talent involved alone
seemed to set up the historical drama
for Success there's also a considerable
amount of pre-release hype for
Oppenheimer playing some parts which
share premiere date with director Greta
gerwig's Barbie the excitement for
double features of the two seeming polar
opposite films have been palpable to say
the least it said perhaps improbable
reason for such positive word of mouth
but it's working more than 20 000 people
have already bought tickets to see both
movies on the same day there's also the
master of our critics who saw it early
as saying Oppenheimer held its World
premiere in Paris on July 11th and soon
after early thoughts flooded Twitter
based on those early reviews it looks
like Nolan has hit yet another cinematic
home run after describing Oppenheimer as
fearsome vultures bilji Berry called it
a relentlessly paced insanely detailed
intricate historical drama that builds
and builds and builds until Nolan brings
a hammer down in the most astonishing
shattering way the Sunday Times Jonathan
Dean also gave Oppenheimer a glowing
review specifically touting the film's
tension and the acting work of Murphy
Matt Damon Robert Downey Jr and Alden
aaronreich while also giving Murphy High
marks total films Matt matum added the
scale the sound and visuals were
awe-inspiring given the subject matter
of Oppenheimer the development of the
atomic bomb it shouldn't be too
surprising that it's also a harrowing
watch this is a matter of life and death
GQ Francis Adam Sanchez commented
Christopher Nolan wanders on the the
mind of Oppenheimer and transforms the
ravages of the past into worries for the
World of Tomorrow Sanchez also described
the film as an extraordinary experience
likewise the telegraph's Robbie Collins
said he was moved to Tears by the time
the credits rolled else they cast last
year variety reported that audiences
were so impacted by the film that they
stayed at the Grand Rex Theater after it
ended to discuss and debater Nolan has a
pretty solid track record as a director
an Interstellar one even The Dark Knight
trilogy Inception Memento and even
sometimes overlooked efforts like the
prestige all after moviegoers flawed in
their time amounting to one of the most
impressive filmographies of the modern
era despite how remarkable those efforts
were some folks aren't afraid to call it
early of the films he's made over his
career Oppenheimer is one of if not the
absolute best Nolan has ever directed
right from producer Ben mackler tweeted
Oppenheimer maybe Nolan's Masterpiece he
predicted that it will more than likely
be an Oscar Contender down the road
Jonathan dimple Oppenheimer alongside
Memento and the pristine age in his
personal top three Northern movies Simon
Thompson of the playlist wasn't afraid
to apply words like perfect and
impeccable to the feature and some of
its key elements the countdown to the
theatrical release of Oppenheimer hit
zero on July 21st